540 here on a Friday morning and today
we are observing Nevada day schools
government buildings are closed makes it
a perfect time to learn more about our
unique history and possibly nothing is
as unique as the Mob Museum downtown and
joining us live this morning from the
Mob Museum it's our friend shaquela
alvaringa Shakeela good morning to you
good to see you again
good morning John thank you so much for
having us yeah we are getting ready for
really a fun-filled community event here
at the Mob Museum so today is Nevada day
if you don't know we are welcoming
everyone from the community to really
come down here and to mingle with us we
will have several interactive
experiences games giveaways live music
food right down here at the Mob Museum
from 10 a.m until two o'clock in the
afternoon this really is an event for
the community and it's a part of our
larger mission for our commitment to
community here in the downtown Las Vegas
a community so we are very excited to
have everyone here we'll have Las Vegas
fire and rescue here trick-or-treating
at several different booths vendor
booths down here at the Mob Museum and
so we're we're excited and we're
welcoming everyone from the community to
really come out here and and gather
together
and Shakila you know I've been at the
mom Museum before and I think a lot of
viewers may have been there already but
there's so much in there it's worth
going back and if you haven't been there
before it's more than just a museum
about the mob what what can people learn
about Las Vegas that maybe they haven't
learned before
yeah well today Nevada day it's really
an opportunity to bring different
organizations that are doing a lot of
good work in our community so we have
safeness joining us the center will be
here as I mentioned before Las Vegas
fire and rescue Metro will be also here
to offer Halloween safety tips for of
course this is a busy weekend here in
Las Vegas so a lot of different
organizations that are doing some good
work in our community will be here to
answer any questions that residents may
have it's very cool stuff Shakila
alvaringa From the Mob Museum downtown
here on Nevada they observed it's good
to see you once again and enjoy the rest
of your morning appreciate it